[Music]
on this saturday night being vaccinated
against coveted 19.
how canadians feel about taking it and
why the message needs to be clear
this process should be starting and
should be continued
throughout the course of the pandemic as
case numbers climb across the country
covert 19 takes the life of a child
in manitoba covet 19 long haulers
i can't really physically or mentally
exert myself without having
a relapse of symptoms the symptoms that
just won't go away
plus sweden switching up its strategy as
a second wave hits hard
and beyond big box stores why holiday
shoppers need to remember
those small businesses
global national with robin gill
reporting tonight
sonia diol good evening and thanks for
joining us we start with a tragic
reminder that covert 19 can affect
anybody at any age health officials in
manitoba say a boy from winnipeg
under the age of 10 has died from the
illness it is unclear if he had any
underlying health conditions
but he is the youngest victim in that
province
manitoba has the highest number of
active cases with many more
new infections being reported today 487
new cases confirmed today
its third highest single day tally in
other provinces quebec shattered its
highest single day record with more than
1400 people
testing positive over the last 24 hours
there were another 1800
new cases in ontario for the second day
in a row
and in alberta a staggering new one-day
record
with over 1700 new infections being
reported
the rapid rise in those case numbers
spelling the urgency
for a vaccine but as michael couture
explains
the number of canadians who want
vaccinations to be made mandatory
is dropping even as those case numbers
go up
as preparations for a mass vaccination
program ramp up
there is concern not every canadian will
line up
for the covid19 vaccine a new ipsos poll
for global news
shows 59 percent of respondents believe
vaccines should be mandatory
but that's down 13 points from may of
this year
we find that that number tends to break
down a bit
when you start going through some of
those concerns so the true number of the
pop
percentage of the population that would
probably get a vaccine right away is
closer to maybe about 20 percent
71 percent of respondents are nervous
the vaccine might have been rushed
through approval and nearly the same
amount
worry about possible side effects still
more than half of canadians say they'd
take the vaccine as soon as they could
reassuring to health professionals who
acknowledged this
isn't risk-free however i personally
have greater fear
of the effects of a wild virus than i do
of the effects of a controlled vaccine
this week the liberal government
announced major general danny forte
will be in charge of the effort to get
vaccines to canadians
in an interview on the west block with
mercedes stevenson
farte said work has already begun this
is so
important that a specific
tailor-made operation center is being
put in place
it includes military officers and ncos
but also
a number of public health agency
employees one of the keys of an
effective rollout is a communication
campaign
making sure people understand the
importance of getting vaccinated
and it takes time to build trust in
communities
it's something that's done at a local
level not
at a thirty thousand foot level so this
process should be starting and should be
continued
throughout the course of the pandemic in
canada a health canada approval for a
vaccine could
come in the next few weeks or even
sooner
the financial times is reporting the uk
will approve the pfizer
and bioentech vaccine next week meaning
brits could be rolling up their sleeves
as early as december 7th sonia
michael couture in ottawa tonight thank
you
well this week prime minister justin
trudeau said when a vaccine
is ready canada will be ready but not
everybody is convinced
that canadians will have access as
quickly as other countries
premieres in particular this week on the
west block saskatchewan premier scott mo
shares his concern canada is getting
pushed further back here in the waiting
line
mercedes stephenson joins us now with
more on that and a look ahead to this
week's edition of the west blog mercedes
sonya the prime minister and his team
keep pointing to the hundreds of
millions of vaccine doses
that canada has signed agreements for
the trudeau government has
deals with seven different vaccine
developers
and health canada says it could approve
a first vaccine
as soon as next month but the leading
vaccines will all be manufactured
outside of canada so the big question is
when they will be delivered to this
country i spoke with saskatchewan
premier scott moe
he says the federal government isn't
doing enough to get its hands on those
vaccines
and should do more as soon as possible
what's troubling about this is we're
seeing not just the producing countries
like the uk and uh and the us
that are going to be out with full-scale
vaccinations sometime here in december
but many other countries that seem to be
gaining a quicker access to these
vaccines than we have here in canada so
we need a more ambitious procurement
program for sure all throughout this
week we heard concerns that canada is
slipping further back in the line
to receive its share of that desperately
wanted vaccine
the country's top health officials have
said that canada's initial supply
will be limited but that every canadian
will have the opportunity to be
vaccinated
dominic leblanc the federal minister of
intergovernmental affairs
insisted on the west block that canada
will be
among the first five countries to get
the pfizer vaccine
our government decided at the very
beginning to ensure that we were
aggressive and robust
in procuring binding agreements so that
when these vaccines are
safe for use in canada as determined by
independent scientific expertise
we would be ready to vaccinate canadians
efficiently and effectively
so more than nine months into this
pandemic we're seeing some light perhaps
at the end of the tunnel but still lots
of questions about just
when most canadians will receive that
vaccination
and canada's readiness we'll dig into
all of that and more on the show
sonya mercedes stevenson in oshawa thank
you
and you can watch the west block with
mercedes stevenson tomorrow
right here on global the u.s
is expecting to have its first doses of
the covert 19 vaccine in a matter of
weeks
health officials will be holding an
emergency meeting next week to decide
who is going to get it first
more than 13 million americans have now
tested
positive for the virus and over 265 000
people
have died but as jennifer johnson
reports there's a growing fear that the
worst
is still yet to come as the cobit 19
pandemic continues to spiral out of
control in the u.s
an advisory panel with the centers for
disease control and prevention
has called an emergency meeting tuesday
it will vote on who will get the vaccine
first when it's approved
cedars-sinai hospital in los angeles has
ultra cold
freezers ready for hundreds of thousands
of doses
the vaccines are becoming available
right at the time that we're
experiencing another surge
so the nurses who commonly would be the
ones to administer the vaccine
are needed at the bedside to care for
covid patients
by next week it's estimated a quarter of
all u.s hospitals will have staffing
shortages
in some areas workers with the virus but
no symptoms
are being told to return it is a mixed
message
to the public to allow asymptomatic
coded positive nurses
physicians and other health care workers
to work there you go with the virus
rapidly spreading local officials are
being forced to take desperate steps to
slow the spread
a three-week stay-at-home order in los
angeles county the nation's largest
starts monday prohibiting all public and
private gatherings
deaths in the county have recently
tripled just two weeks ago we were
looking at maybe 1200 cases a day
and now we're at 4700 cases a day
doctors are begging people to stay home
and stop socializing
a warning ignored by millions over the
thanksgiving holiday
we will not get a reprieve because then
christmas comes and then new year comes
so if we're just stacking search upon
surge upon surge i am significantly
worried about that
every day well over a thousand americans
die of covet 19
those who survive know how lucky they
are it's really
frightening i thought an asthma attack
was frightening
it's expected healthcare workers and
those living in long-term nursing home
facilities
will be the first to receive the vaccine
the food and drug administration will
meet with its advisors about the vaccine
rollout plan
december 10th jennifer johnson global
news
washington well as covert 19 cases grow
around the world so too does the
condition known as long covid
that is when symptoms continue for weeks
even months after a person is no longer
considered contagious
a uk study done early in the pandemic
found two to three percent of patients
were still suffering from challenging
symptoms but america's top
infectious disease expert believes 25
to 35 percent of those infected will
become long haulers
a new clinic is now open in canada
studying how
when and if long haulers will get better
robin gill reports
katie mclean can't go anywhere can't see
anyone
because of what copic 19 has done to her
health
i can't really physically or mentally
exert myself without having
a relapse of symptoms mclean tested
positive for the virus in september
she had all the symptoms cough shortness
of breath
a racing heart and debilitating
exhaustion
nine weeks after her diagnosis she's
still suffering from those same symptoms
it makes me worry about you know what
about the rest of my life and and what's
that going to look like
mclean is part of a group called covet
long haulers
a term used to describe those who have
symptoms well after the virus has left
their system
at st paul's hospital canada's first
post-covet clinic
a team of specialists is trying to
understand the conundrum
of the long-term effects of covid it's a
little bit too early in the game for me
to give you
like statistics and an age range for who
is suffering these symptoms i can tell
you that i'm seeing a lot of people
under the age of 50
that are having sort of ongoing symptoms
i'm seeing people over the age of 50 as
well
doctors are learning from patients as
they go along we don't have enough time
to really say how long these symptoms
are going to happen for
because this is a novel disease and we
are following them along the journey of
their illness
the answers may be found in the 160
patients they're treating
because they're also the backbone of
crucial research at the clinic have you
taken anything for the fever
jacqueline robinson is part of the study
as a nurse
and a patient the 42-year-old contracted
the virus during the first wave
in march now i've had covet and ended up
on a ventilator
hugely passionate about coveted research
and helping this patient population
and i want to give back that's my heart
i want to help other patients and
families
who are going through this as for katie
mclean
she has many more rounds of tests in her
future do you feel like a guinea pig
i do a bit because we don't we just
don't know
how this is going to play out yet for
now she's taking it day by day
even though each step she takes still
takes her breath away
robin gill global news vancouver
and robin delves deeper into the
problems plaguing long haulers tonight
at seven on the new reality you can
watch that right here on global
the ontario police officer fatally shot
in the line of duty on mala tuna island
earlier this month was laid
to rest today
an investigation into constable mark
hoving's death
is still ongoing another civilian also
died in hospital after the shooting in
gore bay on the 19th of november
during today's funeral service opp
commissioner
thomas carrickay said constable mark
hoving was nothing short of heroic
and he approached every day with bravery
his wife leanne thanked the community
for the outpouring of support
and the ocean of love for the family
still ahead the anger in india as
farmers clash with police
to make it to new delhi we'll tell you
why in just a couple of minutes
welcome back well ethiopia's government
claims to be in control
of the capital of the tigray region
after more than three weeks of intense
fighting
military forces entered the city of
mckele today
in a final offensive against the tea
great people's liberation front
communications in the region have been
cut making details of the assault
difficult to confirm but on twitter
today ethiopian prime minister abe ahmed
claimed the military has ceased
operations in the tigray region
and the focus is now on rebuilding and
providing humanitarian assistance
since the conflict started earlier this
month more than 40 000 refugees fled the
region
seeking shelter in sudan thousands of
angry indian farmers protesting
agricultural reforms have been allowed
into new delhi
after violent clashes with police who
fired tear gas at them to try and keep
them out
the farmers are being escorted to a
protest site in the city they started
the march on thursday
to pressure prime minister narendra modi
to scrap the laws that they fear will
cut back their earnings
and give more power to corporations
tensions are running high between iran
and israel tonight iran's supreme leader
ayatollah ali khamenei
is vowing revenge after the killing of
the country's chief
nuclear scientist he says the work will
continue
aired today on iranian state television
according to their reporting
fake rosary was ambushed and killed by
gunmen on the outskirts of tehran on
friday
western intelligence agencies believe
fakarazadeh was behind a covert
iranian nuclear weapons programme
nobody's claimed responsibility for the
attack
but iran is blaming israel still ahead
sweden ramping up its relaxed pandemic
strategy
as a second wave is hitting the country
hard
sweden has so far resisted a national
lockdown but it's rethinking its
strategy after recording a surge of
second wave infections
tonight its citizens are being told to
stay home
strict measures also going into effect
as crystal gaban singh reports sweden
has been slammed for taking a lack's
attitude towards covet 19
but is now being hit with more deaths
than its neighbors
there are few masked faces in stockholm
but these
outdoor spaces are covered with those
familiar warnings
to keep your distance a second wave of
covet 19
is hitting sweden the big debates on the
tv all the time how we should
manage this and so on so i i don't think
we are easy going
we are we are affected by this disease
as every other country
dr johann lunegaard is the chief medical
officer at sweden's oldest university
hospital
he doesn't subscribe to the theory of
countries being coveted 19 winners or
losers
strategies work until they don't and
right now he says his staff is exhausted
and in a tough situation up to one-fifth
of all the patients in the hospital's
hospital or kobe patients
and almost half of the intensive care
unit patients
are covered patients at the moment
transmission rates in sweden are
substantially higher than a neighboring
norway denmark and finland with more
than 240
000 confirmed cases the loss of life in
other scandinavian countries where
lockdowns have been in place off and on
for months
is substantially less in sweden there's
been roughly 65 deaths per 100 000
people
while in denmark that number is roughly
14 in finland
it drops to 7 per 100 000 and in norway
it's six swedish officials admit there
appears to be little evidence of herd
immunity
and infections continue to rise in an
effort to curb social gatherings
nationally
alcohol cannot be sold after 10 pm in
restaurants bars or nightclubs
and formal public gatherings have been
reduced from 50 people
to eight what we do know from
local reports is that it has changed
behavior with people
we can see that more people are starting
to work from home under huston
sweden's prime minister stefan lowen
made a rare national address last
weekend telling people to cancel their
plans
and stay home but that is just a
suggestion
it seems like the the swedish population
take it more seriously
as infections and hospitalizations rise
the swedish statistical agency says that
for the first time
in a century life expectancy in the
country
will drop because of covid19
as for the current rate of transmission
it's hoped the new measures will start
to drive down infections
crystal gomansing global news london
the vatican is marking a historic moment
wilton gregory the archbishop
of washington dc has become the first
black cardinal
from the u.s the 72 year old was one of
13
new cardinals blessed by pope francis on
saturday
in june gregory blasted president
trump's visit to a historic washington
church
when soldiers had to use tear gas and
rubber bullets they say to clear
anti-racism protesters along the way
shop so they don't drop coming up how
local businesses are
banking on your loyalty
well despite pleas from health officials
across the country
thousands of canadians spent black
friday in a shopping centre
this is what it looked like yesterday in
calgary's largest mall
many shoppers were wearing masks but
there was almost no physical distancing
police had to be called in to disperse
the crowd in ontario at least six
businesses in the york region were fined
for not following public health rules
well this weekend
is typically one of the busiest shopping
times of the year but
many stores have been forced to close or
stop in-person sales because of the
pandemic
this time of year also crucial for the
survival of small businesses
and as catherine ward explains there's
concern that online sales alone
may not be enough to save them
there is just something just to be said
for the
human connection kara kennedy has run
her high-end consignment shop in toronto
for the last four and a half years
people have always been able to shop
online from anywhere in the world
but she says it's the in-store purchases
that have been key
for the bottom line there's a lot of
stuff in our store that's pretty high
quality
and you really have to touch and feel it
to to want to buy it in person
so it's really hard to replicate that
experience online last year 75 percent
of kennedy's sales came from in-store
purchases with more lockdowns rolling
out
small businesses across the country
continue to struggle
as governments try to balance
restrictions and safety
in light of covid19 recent data from the
canadian federation of independent
business suggests
only 38 percent of retail shops are
hitting normal sales compared
to this time last year and one in seven
are at risk of shutting down permanently
on monday the canadian government is
expected to deliver its fall
economic statement experts say they hope
more will be offered for small and
medium-sized stores there are still tens
of thousands of businesses slipping
through the cracks of the wage subsidy
the rent subsidy and the sibo loan
program
we're hoping that the government will
announce fixes to them especially for
new businesses new businesses started in
2020
they don't qualify for any of the
programs digital experts say
investing in paid advertising can help
leverage
a small business online but they say the
best thing owners can do
is to tap into their current customer
base what are you doing for your loyal
customers are you giving them incentives
to sort of share what are you doing with
the email list that you already have are
you
you know emailing out customers telling
them about promotions telling what you
have
kennedy says so far she has seen an
increase in online sales
and remains thankful for the customers
who are choosing
local options they know that small
business is important and people are
actively seeking to buy from small
business
and i think that is going to save us
catherine ward global news toronto
and that is global national for this
saturday i'm sonia diol tonight's your
canada is the snowy fields outside of
airdrie
in alberta do send your photos to
viewers at globalnational.com thanks
very much for watching
i'll see you back here tomorrow good
night